-It is great to have you here.
Thanks so much for coming on.
-Thanks for finally
having me on.
-I can't believe that you've
never been --
-I know.
I feel like we have, too.
-Maybe on "Late Night"
or something.
We have.
We've hung out or something.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. Something.
-I know you.
But maybe it's just because
I'm a fan.
-Me too. I know.
That's strange how that happens.
-You have an amazing history,
though, with "The Tonight Show."
-Why, yes, I do.
-I love this story.
-Yes.
-Is it your -- Who was it, now?
This is your grandfather?
-My grandfather was a comedian
called Cliff Arquette,
but he had a character he
invented called Charley Weaver.
-I mean, Charley Weaver.
I totally remember
Charley Weaver.
That is Jack Paar.
That's your grandfather,
Cliff Arquette.
This is "The Tonight Show,"
1959.
-Yes, exactly.
-And this is at
the Hudson Theatre.
But that's wild.
-Yeah.
-Do you remember telling
stories about these days?
-Well, my grandpa was
in Vaudeville.
And when he was 14,
he went around the country
playing at speakeasies,
the trumpet.
And then he did live radio.
He was Slap-happy Grandpappy
on these, like,
live radio comedy shows.
-Isn't that wild?
-And then he retired,
but he'd created this
character, Charley Weaver.
And everyone was watching
"The Jack Paar Show,"
because it was just this
huge phenomena.
And he was watching one night,
and Jack said,
"You know who used to
crack me up?
Charley Weaver.
What happened to him?
What happened to
Charley Weaver?"
And my grandpa
had been watching,
so he wrote him,
typed him a letter.
"I'm alive. I'm good.
I'm retired.
Thanks for thinking of me.
I love your show."
And, so, Jack Paar
wrote him back and said,
"Why don't you come on my show."
And then he became
a semi-regular.
And then he got
"Hollywood Squares,"
and he had this
whole second career.
-Isn't that amazing?
-Yeah.
-I love that.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So, did your parents encourage
you to get into show business?
Because --
-No. My mom wanted to cry.
She was like, "Please!
Please! Your principal said
you could be a doctor.
Why are you doing this?"
-"Your principal said --" Yeah.
-Yeah.
-But I read somewhere
that you did this.
You said,
"I'm going to try acting.
I'm going to give it a year.
And if I don't do it in a year,
I'm not going to do it."
But what was plan B?
Do you --
-I was going to be a midwife.
Yeah, that was my plan B.
-That was your plan B?
-Yeah.
And it's --
You know, someday, I'll still --
maybe I'll be a midwife.
Who knows?
-Yeah, I mean, I think acting is
going pretty well for you.
-It is. Thank you.
-Yeah.
-Thank you, Lord. But -- Yeah.
-But what was that year like?
Would you audition and just --
-Yeah. Well, the thing is,
I love both these ideas,
but I was actually
shy and scared.
"What if I'm a bad actress?"
or "I don't want to be doing
this for 30 years
and never get anywhere.
So I'm going to give myself
one year,
because what I want
more than being a midwife
or being an actress,
to be a brave person.
So I'm going to say,
for one year,
I'm going to go on this
quest to be brave.
So, every day, since it's more
frightening for me
to try to be an actress,
I'm going to try to be
an actress every day for a year
and be willing to fail."
So, I'd go on
these auditions sometimes.
I went on this audition.
It went so bad.
And they called
my agent afterwards.
And they were like,
"She was horrible!
I mean, that was the
worst audition I ever saw.
Oh, my --
What was she thinking?"
And I was like, "Yeah!
I'm so brave!
I'm going out again.
-I'm doing my brave --
I'm doing my year of brave.
-Well, I also said to them,
"Excuse me.
That was no part at all."
It was, like,
this dumb secretary part.
She did nothing.
So, in the audition,
I was like, "Oh, hi.
Oh, Mr. Grant.
Oh, I think I dropped my papers.
I'm sorry."
You know.
-Yeah.
-I just made her really
fumbly-bumbly,
and they thought
that's who I was
and that I just wasn't prepared.
But I was like, "Hell no.
Call them back and tell them
that was a choice."
-Yeah! "I made that part
interesting."
-Exactly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, obviously, I did a good
job, because they were pissed.
-They were -- Yeah.
Mission accomplished.
-Exactly.
-"Severance" season finale airs
Friday on Apple TV+.
-Yeah, and we just got picked up
for a second season.
-You did? Oh!
Come on, now!
-Right.
-That's fantastic. I love that.
-Waffle party!
-Yes!
-At my house. No.
-It's a great concept.
I remember we had Ben here to
talk about it, Ben Stiller,
who directed
most of the episodes.
But it's trippy
and it's really good.
It's kind of like --
How would we describe it?
It's not -- It's, like, a dry --
It's, like, a dark comedy,
but it's also -- It's not
sci-fi, but kind of is.
-Well, yeah, exactly.
When we were shooting,
I was asking him, too,
"What's the tone here?"
And I was like, "Is this a retro
sci-fi soap opera?
Is this -- What is this?
Is this --"
At moments, it's film noir.
Then it's comedy.
I mean, it was really tricky.
But Ben knew the tone
the whole time.
-You can get a thing
implanted in your brain
so that when you
clock into work,
all you remember is
your workday,
and then,
once you clock out of work,
all you remember is
your outside workday.
-Yeah, you can't remember
anything at work
when you're home
and you can't remember anything
at home when you're at work.
-Exactly.
We really explained it --
Where were you
when we had Ben on?
I was, like, fumbling.
That's perfect. We nailed it.
I didn't think it was that easy
to describe, but yes.
And it's really good
and beautifully shot
and it's trippy.
You're so great in it.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Patricia Arquette
in "Severance."
Take a look at this.
-It's not your job to play
nursemaid to every new refiner.
-Okay. So, what is my job?
-Are you really asking me that?
-Yeah.
What is it we actually do here?
-We serve Kier, you child!
And until you get that through
your mildewed little brain
and hit quota,
MDR's hallway privileges
are hereby revoked.
So get your little ass
back to your desk
and stay there
until you're told to move.
♪♪
-Yes! Come on!
-Ooh! Scary lady.
-That's how you do it!
That is how you do it.
I'm so happy you're here.
You know,
we were talking backstage,
and you mentioned
that there's something
you want to bring awareness to.
And I would like
to talk about it.
-Thank you so much.
You know, I try to follow the
Center for Missing and
Endangered Kids.
And on my Twitter feed
came up this little boy,
Simjie Morrison.
He's 12 years old.
He has no known family,
no known relatives,
and he went missing
in Philadelphia.
But because he's under --
he's over 10
and they don't know
he was abducted,
they never put out
an Amber Alert.
So, he went missing in Philly.
He's very small.
He only weighs 72 pounds.
He's 5 feet tall.
Please look at the Center for
Missing & Endangered Kids
and look at his picture.
Simjie Morrison.
And if you happen to see him --
New York, Philly, New Jersey,
call 1-800-THE-LOST.
-1-800-THE-LOST.
Do we know where
he was seen last?
-He was seen in Philly.
He went missing from
this sort of
foster-care facility called
Forget Me Knot.
-Guys, if anyone knows
anything about this,
call 1-800-THE-LOST.
And I appreciate you bringing
that to our attention,
and maybe somebody --
That'd be amazing.
-Yeah, please.
-Patricia Arquette, everyone.
The season finale of "Severance"
airs this Friday on Apple TV+.